on n'a pas trouvé la solution et c'est
vrai que sur le plan purement écologique
de dit ok on n'a plus besoin de camions
plus de plastique pet rapide solide de
de soutien matériel directement du
studio à ton salon c'est fantastique
mais tous les gens qui ont fait ces
véhicules low life on n'échappe à quoi
ils sont tous devenus milliardaires et
les seuls qui sont pas payés c'est le
fond de la mine c'est les auteurs les
compositeurs les arrange les musiciens
les chefs d'orchestre et les chanteurs
enfin beaucoup de chanteurs qui n'ont
pas la chance peut-être où tous ces gens
là qui ne font qu écrire ou produire en
studio peuvent plus gagner leur vie
la seule la dernière course et la scène
toujours dit innocent et sinon et bien
sûr internet
il faut 200 passages pour avoir une
sainte alors supposons qu'on partage
acclamant dont une chanson à deux ou
avec d'autres avec move maintenant pour
l'ordinaire et bien là il faut que ça
passe 200 fois par mois en 2016 c'est
comme ridicule puis bin des fois ceux
qui ont la chance comme clermont donc il
fallait que pau pitié je pense qu'on a
reçues des 58 7 années bush thème commun
il peut renvoyer d'écouter ça coûte
pichet de papier que garde des vagues